welcome to this week's episode as you
know we are partnering with QT which is
a social media company that's trying to
create healthy conversations we'd love
you to join us in that conversation and
give us your thoughts on the biggest
questions that we're currently
discussing in society this week the
conversation we're hosting is about the
future of the Labor Party and would
really love your input and it's not just
the future the Labor Party it's also the
future of leftist parties right the way
across the world what do you think
left-wing policies need to be because at
the moment I think we can all agree the
left is in crisis so come on join the
conversation and let's get these ideas
shared and once you've got the feedback
for us they're what we tend to do every
week is on our live streams we'll read
out some of the comments we'll discuss
them will crack a few jokes
we'll get you input and that's why we
love qts because they create an
opportunity for healthy conversations
there's very little trolling very little
spam on there that's why it's great so
head on click that link head on over
there and we'll see you in a couple of
days with our live stream yeah I think
there are people in the labour party who
would be comfortable with with just
being a protest movement to be honest
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constance and kissin
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest this week is
a firefighter trade unionist and a
columnist for the unheard website Paul
Embry welcome back to trigonometry nice
to be back yeah you're back sure faster
than most of our other guests because a
lot of things have happened and not
least with your career you've had a bit
of a change since the last time we spoke
to you so tell us a little bit about the
situation with you in your unions yeah I
had a bit of an enforced enforced change
it wasn't so it wasn't something that I
was I was particularly asking for but
the last time I was on the I was on the
show I was in on the national executive
of the Fire Brigades Union at my
firefighter by trade and was also a
senior official in the fire brigade
Union but I made the the fatal error of
speaking at a pro brexit rally on the
29th of March last year which was the
date we were originally supposed to
leave the European Union and I spoke at
a cross-party rally and within the
within the speech that I gave I was
specifically critical of leaders of the
labor movement over their position on
brexit and I expressed some degree of
criticism and and that was it that was
the that was the impetus for the for the
Fire Brigades Union to take me through
an internal discipline process and and
to find that even though I had given
that speech in my own sign on a Friday
evening even though I hadn't spoken on
behalf of fibre gauge Union there was no
mention of the Fire Brigades Union I was
speaking on behalf of trade unionists
against the EU which is a group I've
been involved with for a long time and I
had acted in a way prejudicial to the
interests of the of the Union and an
almost kicked out of office and banned
from holding office again for two years
so despite the fact that they're there
as it's Article II been a really rich
tradition within the five agos Union of
open debate and people being allowed to
express their view particularly when
they're doing it in a
personal capacity this was this was
pretty much an unprecedent it move and
it disappointing because I've been an
FPU official for 20 years but but that
was that I don't think it's quite over
yet because I'm pursuing it through
either through other avenues but but
yeah there was some fallout from that
and I think it's fair to say that there
is backfire to a certain degree on the
people responsible for it that's it
there we go well let's see what we can
do more to make it backfire more but
essentially what you're talking about is
being punished for expressing your
political views in a private capacity
just so you just show off Harry Miller
who have recently had on the show you
didn't have the police call you up and
check your thinking on brexit but but
I'm sure some people might have wanted
to put the police on to me yeah that's
that's exactly right I mean obviously if
you if you are an official for a trade
union particularly when you're in a
senior capacity then when you're acting
in your capacity as a union official you
have to represent the the union's
position or at least so explain what the
what the union's position is but as I
say it's it's a rich tradition not just
within the FPU but in the trade union
movement generally but if you're not
acting in your Union capacity you're
free third free to express your own view
in your own personal time so for example
when there are trade union meetings it's
not uncommon to see flyers for that
meeting where trade union officials are
speaking but they're not necessarily
putting the union view so you'll have in
brackets after their name personal
personal capacity in a personal capacity
that's very very common in the trade
union movement and as I say you know
it's always been very much a feature of
my trade union previously that we had
the freedom to do that but on this
occasion they decided that no
criticising leaders of the labor
movement for their position on brexit
was was wrong and worthy of being kicked
out of office so that's what happened
and that strikes me as incredible so
essentially they fired you for having a
political opinion how did they justify
it did they was the only justification
was it a simple well the interesting
thing is that since it happened and you
know that there was as I said quite
fierce backlash there's been coverage in
national newspapers The Daily Mirror ran
an investigation in in their
investigations column there was a big
backlash on social media from members of
the fibre Union and even from people who
are not members of the fiber gays Union
there were Labour MPs who wrote blogs
about it saying they were shocked and
concerned at the implications of it and
since the decision though they haven't
actually really even tried to justify it
now I think probably because they
suspect it's gone badly wrong and it
looks very it looks very poor for the
Union and no one the general secretary
who submitted the original complaint
which led to the investigation against
me nor anybody else within the the sort
of senior echelons of the Union has ever
really come out and sought cert sorts of
publicly defend it they've sort of gone
inside a bunker over it really even
though you know it's garnered quite a
lot of coverage and I think that's
probably an indication of the fact that
as I said they realize it hasn't turned
out the way they expected well hopefully
it's through the other avenues that
you're pursuing you get you get some job
what you might call justice mercy we'll
see he's got that little devil look in
his eye like he's gonna get it which is
great but I'm coming back to the broader
reason we wanted to get you back so soon
as you're we looked at our former guest
who we just felt had been massively
vindicated by the election outcome a
month ago as we record this and you you
were absolutely at the top of the list
because you've been talking about
Labour's abandonment of the working
class and the potential for losing Hulse
waves of the country which had
traditionally voted for the Labour Party
and that is exactly what happened in
December 2019 it must be a bittersweet
moment for you personally because your
lifelong labour person so I'm guessing
you were happy to be right but also very
probably despondent about the election
results for your party yeah and I
wouldn't have chosen the result that we
got I would have liked genuinely to have
been proved wrong
but who's been clear to me for a long
time that that schism between Labor
heartlands and the Labour Party was
going to play out in a general election
where we lost a number of traditional
labour sees something that I'd been
predicting for a long time
a few other people had been predicting
it within the party for quite some time
and you don't take any pleasure in
saying I told you so you know I think
you're probably justified in saying when
you know opponents within the party have
you know given you bucket loads of
criticism and abuse over the years for
arguing what you've been arguing and I
don't mind that I mean it's water off a
duck's back but it would be nice to
think that some of these people are a
little bit contrite about about their
position and what they've been arguing
and how spectacularly wrong they've been
proved to be I suspect they won't be
particularly can try I suspect there
won't be much self-reflection and partly
I think because some of these people are
just so certain that they're right and
we're even now when you look at the
scale of the defeat there are people
within the party who just think it can
be explained away by a hostile media or
just simply the issue of brexit and I
mean that was a significant issue no
doubt it wasn't the only issue in the
election or you know the worst one
particularly people on there who come
from the far left is false consciousness
you know these millions of working-class
people voted Tory they really are in
favor of manifesto they really are in
favor of our world view of society they
really are secret you know cosmopolitan
globalist we just need one more heave
mentality we just need to I'll tell you
something recently it reminds me of your
firm you know in a slightly
stereotypical I guess but you know when
an English tourist goes insert into a
shop in Spain or something speaks
English to the assistant and when it's
clear that the assistant doesn't speak
English
they just start talking loud yeah I
think suddenly you know the assistants
going to understand and that strikes me
as you know what lots of people in the
labor part you're doing at the moment
that they they think they got it right
the working class got it wrong and that
all they have to do is shout a little
bit louder at the working class and all
of a sudden the working class will go
home suddenly I understand you're
absolutely right so this is this is
genuinely yes is a bit a cliche to say
is it's a crossroads moment but I think
it genuinely is for the Labour Party I
mean we've suffered our worst defeat
since 1935 the the list of places that
we have lost places that have been labor
up since the 1920s in some cases bowls
over bowls over Dennis skinning an old
mining community bolide Valley Bassett
law Grimsby John van Wrexham Don Valley
Redcar Lee all of these places were
[Laughter]
places that didn't count the Labour
votes they weighed their labour votes
and and what you've got to consider as
well is this is after a decade of a Tory
government which is imposed austerity on
the country all of third you know the
detrimental consequences of that for so
many working-class communities and
working-class people
after three and a half years of absolute
political chaos that this this
government has presided over I mean I'm
obviously Pro brexit but nonetheless I
think the way it's been handled has been
pretty chaotic and labored didn't even
tread water
they got absolutely smashed we got
absolutely smashed by an old Etonian who
these winnings you know some of those
those places that we listed and you know
you look at some of the other figures
the this sort of C 2 DS which is
regarded broadly as the as a sort of
occupational working-class and I know
that's not a perfect sort of
categorization because it also includes
pensioners but nonetheless it's as close
to
we can get really sensitive I'm
working-class people when it comes to
elections they broke 48 percent for the
Tories and 33 percent for labour and
you've got to start as a labor person
you have to ask yourself why after 10
years of austerity as a Tory party led
by an old Etonian after three and a half
years of political chaos absolutely
wipes us out in some of our traditional
working-class Heartland and it's because
of the fact that the Labour Party
increasingly and I you know I've argued
that it's not just a Jeremy Corbyn thing
I think this is a phenomenon that
predates Jeremy called Bensimon power
this is something that's been going on
for years the Labour Party is slowly
been hemorrhaging votes in those
communities over the years and and was
really losing a cultural war that it
didn't even realize that it was fighting
and you saw with the brexit vote in 2016
and how that broke and how you know some
of these traditional working-class areas
and labour heartlands were sort of you
know voting Phillipe as a means to hit
back at the dominant sort of liberal
agenda that Labour was completely signed
up to you saw it in the 2017 election
where you know large parts of the Labour
Party were triumphalist almost after an
election you know because they because
we in the party did better than anyone
who thought it wasn't quite the
catastrophe people expected it was
treated as a victory and in some
respects that was the worst outcome for
labour because what it meant is the
party didn't examine seriously why it
was so removed and was losing so many
votes in its working class heartlands
that 2017 election masked if you like
what the real problem was and then I
think you know the the failure to honor
the referendum result and it was a key
thing that in 2017 the Labour manifesto
said we would honor the referendum
result in 2019 clearly labour wasn't
prepared to do that I think that was
also a significant factor so I think
breaks it was important I think call Ben
to a certain degree clearly wasn't
popular on the doorstep but these
problems have been
have been germinating inside the Labour
Party for years and years and how much
responsibility does momentum need to
take for all this well I mean I'm not
somebody who says that we should be
sectarian about it we should seek to
drum these people out of the party you
know in some respects yeah I wasn't
particularly the anti Corbin
to be honest I mean I think on the
question of austerity he was absolutely
right that austerity was a political
choice or not an economic necessity
I think previous Labour leadership stood
side away for a sight away from making
that case and in facts he was in terms
of the economics of it which was sort of
demonized as sort of hard left marks it
marks a sort of Soviet style economics
actually it was just broadly a Keynesian
sort of philosophy which you see really
in some of the social democratic
countries in Scandinavia for example so
on that side of things I don't think
necessarily he was he was wrong at all
momentum I think in some respects of you
know brought a lot of energy to the
party brought a lot of campaigning ideas
to the party for a lot of enthusiasm to
the party I don't think we need a civil
war a sectarian war I just ask politely
that these people realized that they got
it fundamentally wrong and that their
prescriptions for leading us to power
have been proven to be disastrous the
strategies they employed have absolutely
crashed and burned and actually to show
a little bit of respect so those of us
on the other side of the argument who
have called it riot and said this was
gonna happen when everyone was telling
us in the party no you're exaggerating
you've got an outdated view of the
working class you just pedal in a sort
of nativist reactionary line and I
remember standing up a Labour Party
fringe meetings for example and and in
trade union meetings within the labor
movement and saying to people I'm
telling you that we are creating a huge
schism with our heartlands and it's
going to cause a calamity and a massive
rupture at the future general election
sometime soon and people people looking
bewildered that anyone could even argue
that because they mistook this sort of
internal enthusiasm in the party and the
fact that we were now at mass membership
party with half a million members and
there was this vibrancy and energy
within the party as you know almost like
a microcosm of what was going on in the
country and it really wasn't you know
and that's that's the danger of all
political parties you end up speaking to
your own membership and looking at your
own membership as a reflection of
broader society and the failure on that
has been absolutely huge and people have
got to start recognizing it in the party
and where does the Labour Party go from
here I mean we've talked about kind of
how we are where we are with good win
with their accountant and you've just
spent a good chunk chunk of time laying
it out where does the Labour Party go
from here because it seems to me that
one of the difficulties is creating
coalition between this kind of
metropolitan degree educated elite and
the traditional working-class heartland
is very difficult because culturally the
value systems are so different so does
the Labour Party and I have to make a
choice does it become a party of the
Liberal Metropolitan Lee or a party of
the traditional working class is there a
way to bring those two groups together
how does the Labour Party survive I mean
frankly at this point I think there is a
way to bring them together and in fact
whenever labour is one power in the past
it's generally been buy it by doing that
so my view is for any political party
you have to start with your base your
core vote and then built outwards and
for labour you can look at the history
of the Labour Party it's called though
these working-class people
know that's what it was set up to
represent in those you know some of
those constituencies we listed that the
now gone soaring that's where you start
as a Labour Party now labour will only
succeed electorally in my view and has
historically only succeeded elect
literally when it's been able to
maintain the trust of its core vote at
the same time as appealing to a
sufficient layer of if you like more
middle-class more liberal
less tribal voters and I'm certainly not
somebody who says the path to victory in
the future for the Labour Party is just
to appeal exclusively to the old
industrial working class the you know
we've got to do is appeal to the people
in the dom valleys and the bowls overs
and that's it we're back on the path to
victory actually you know i think it's
good we can win other places like cancer
brilliant kensington and places like
that i think the problem has been
certainly more recently as is that we
have won some of those other places at
the expense and there's if you like the
traditional working-class areas and
that's because as a party we have become
so obsessed with one part of that
equation which is the the sort of
middle-class liberal part of the
equation whilst almost ignoring the the
sort of more traditional working-class
part of the equation and i think that
that a big reason for that is because
the party itself the composition of the
party the demographic of the party has
changed so significantly over the recent
years i've been in the party for 25
years and actually in my time the party
has changed hugely i mean there was a
time where you know you go to a Labour
Party conferences for example and there
would be you know strong working-class
voices there people who had come up
through the trade union movement manual
workers blue-collar workers who were now
trade unionists and ordinary grassroots
members of constituency labor parties
going to Labour Party conference over
the years those voices have become fewer
and fewer and the more dominant voices
have become those sort of middle-class
woke sort of liberal cosmopolitan voices
so the degree now where you go to Labour
Party conferences and you just realize
that it really isn't a reflection of the
country at large 77 percent of the party
come from the sort of abc1 middle class
social grade the party has got hardly
any roots now in many of those
constituencies those sort of
working-class constituencies
unless the party can can find a way of
shifting the the emphasis if you like
from the the sort of middle-class
liberal globalist cosmopolitan city
based element of it back to you know the
traditional working-class areas and
trying to build a coalition you know as
I say build from your base and work out
rather than you know look to that that
sort of a new constituency and hope that
the working-class stays with you which
it didn't then unless the Labour Party
can can do that then I think frankly it
could be it could be out of power for at
least ten years I think there's a
question over the future of the Labour
Party is a party of government a sort I
think there's a danger it becomes a
permanent protest movement in the signs
since the election are not good you know
if you look at some of the frontrunners
for the Labour leadership I think
they're you know they've got nothing
against them personally but I think
they're everything that's wrong with the
Labour Party to a certain degree
you know I've pitched it as we've become
all Hampstead and not enough Hartlepool
over recent years and I think if you
look at people like kiost Alma and Emily
Thornbury and Clyde Lewis those people
are not going to win back some of those
constituencies that we need to win but
what about Rebecca long bailing because
she thought that Corbin's leadership was
ten out of ten yeah she's the one more
heave candidate that's the that's the
truth of it and again nothing personal
I'm sure she's I'm sure she's a very
decent principled woman but the the idea
that you know we just we just didn't try
hard enough
and we didn't sort of push hard enough
and and these people really are on board
with what we're arguing we just need you
know one more heave we just need to
redouble our efforts I think is
delusional there needs to be a
fundamental rethinking of what the party
is about and what it stands for there
needs to be a change in emphasis there
needs to be a change in language we've
got to stop going to places and speaking
about issues that are not what I would
call sort of solar plexus issues and
they're not issues that hit voters in
the gut when you talk about them because
they really resonate with them so for
example labor activists will obsess
and talked incessantly about things like
climate change and human rights and
gender fluidity and LGBT issues and
migrant rights and stuff like that I'm
not saying those things don't have that
place of course those things needs to be
discussed for many labor activist it
seems to be all they want to talk about
because if you go to some of those
communities where we lost the things
that people want to talk about other
things that actually really matter to
them you want to talk about work they
want to talk about family they want to
talk about law and order they want to
talk about immigration and the impacts
of immigration they want to talk about
having a welfare system that is based
more around the principle of reciprocity
you know something for something rather
than universal entitlement which issues
actually that once upon a time were were
the labor movement broadly was entirely
comfortable speaking about because these
were working-class issues and the Labour
Party represented working-class people
but when you speak to labor activist
about those issues now though I ever
sort of look down and shuffle their
shoes in embarrassment or they just
dismiss you as some sort of bigger and
it's a huge problem in the police record
that labor activists talking about
gender fluidity a good YouTube show but
as you're listing all those things you
know law and order right what was some
of the other things you said you said
law and order it work family family
immigration immigration society right
there was a party in the last election
that spoke about all of those things the
Conservative Party and that's why they
presumably they won those seats and they
won those people oh because they're
actually speaking the language of of
that group of people they got it they
got it Dom Dominic Cummings and Boris
Johnson got it totally and it pains me
to say I am a bitter opponent of Boris
Johnson Boris I'm a firefighter and
Boris Johnson closed ten of our fire
stations in London a few years ago when
he was mayor of London and we fought in
campaign against him and Boris Johnson
has got no time for trade unions Boris
Johnson is somebody who sits on
obviously side of the political spectrum
to me
but he understood and I think more
pertinently Dominic Cummings behind the
scenes understood that actually there
was Mathew Goodwin one of your former
guests has described it as a sweet spot
in British politics and I think he's
right which is a place where millions of
people are and until now most mainstream
parties just won't get in it which is
where people yes sit on the left
economically so they're very happy to
have a party that's is actually the gap
between rich and poor is too wide we
need to close it actually there's a lack
of investment in some of our regions and
we need to have a government that
intervenes and invests in infrastructure
you know government that sort of raises
the minimum wage for example government
that addresses those regional
inequalities a government that is tough
on some of the boardroom scandals and
corporate fat cats and some of that
stuff's been described as Corbin onyx
and I think some of that stuff really
did resonate with working-class people
that's where they were what the Tories
got this time around and what Labour
hasn't got for years is that those
people are also if you like cultural
traditionalists and one not just the
economic security and fairness but
cultural security cultural stability as
well not in AE some people would
describe as some sort of xenophobic
nativist white supremacist that's the
level of debate with some people but
actually just the type of politics where
their sense of place is respected their
sense of belonging is respect see if
they don't like the negative effects of
globalization in the way that you know
it can root communities it can D
resonate communities and families and it
just leaves them you know leave them
scout so that sort of four wins and they
you know they like stability and
tradition and and custom so if you like
you know people are left when it comes
to economics and a bit right when it
comes to culture and Social Policy and
the Tories I think exploited that
perfectly and that's why you know after
after 10 years of torial Stara tea they
were still able to go into those
communities and win and win
laborer votes now I think the problem
for the Labour Party is that there are
so few people first who understand that
analysis and second are actually
prepared to do something about it
so you know it talks about that I talked
about the leadership election I mean so
far as so far as some of the candidates
are talking about at least an ending is
one for example is articulating some of
these ideas and you get the feeling that
it doesn't really come from the gut that
actually it's just really a hard-headed
assessment of where we need to be to get
labour back to power now okay at least
she's talking about it but we need
people in the party at the top level of
the party and at the grassroots of the
party who get this from the gut if you
like and the only way to do that is to
have a much greater sort of influence
within the party from those
working-class communities but the truth
is people traditional labour voters
tribal labour voters are once upon a
time tribal labour vote is in these
communities now look at the party more
and more and say actually the leadership
of the party the membership of the party
doesn't look like me it doesn't speak
like me doesn't work in jobs like me
doesn't understand you know my
priorities why should I vote for them
and that chasm is going to be very very
difficult to close and do you think in
many ways so when you're talking about
the Labour Party it just occurred to me
now I mean what we're really talking
about is the Lib Dems aren't we that's
what they've sort of turned into with a
slightly more left-of-center economic
policy I mean I've sort of been involved
in in politics pretty much all my adult
life and I've never quite understood
what it's a big problem that Labour
seems like it's moving towards that
direction where they increasingly
talking to a small and smaller sliver of
society yeah I think there are people in
the labour party who would be
comfortable with with just being a
protest movement to be honest it's a
very unappealing mix now the Labour
Party of what I would sort of describe
as on the one hand a sort of very middle
class while
liberal contingent liberal cosmopolitan
contingent on the one hand and on the
other through momentum and and other
sort of organizations a more sort of far
left I would call a bit the toy some
revolutionary group of people and I've
sort of described it as a party of Lenin
and Lenin John Wayne which really you
know it doesn't doesn't resonate with
ordinary working-class people it's all
in in many respects and there are people
particularly from the the sort of second
part of that equation this sort of far
left a revolutionary type of that
equation you know lots of students for
example who are in their early years of
political activity and a quite infused
by you know going out and shout you know
Tory and easily protesting on the
streets and you know we've all been
there and done it but actually if you if
you're serious about it
you have to recognize that if you
serious about winning power it's about
compromise it's about recognizing that
sometimes you might be wrong on stuff
and being prepared so reflect on stuff
not just trying to dismiss the fact that
working-class people don't agree with
you as a false consciousness and and
being prepared to sort of take the hard
decisions and make the tough ideological
leaps sometimes to realize what it needs
to take power but you know that element
of the party there are lots of people
who I mean I had a debate with one of
them on Twitter recently and and he said
something like you know he started the
new year as he left the old year getting
pissed defending free movement and
denouncing Paul Emery life goes on there
it's great you can make self feel good
in that way but actually there are
people out there in need a Labour
government and the Labour Party was out
so we empower to represent those people
and if you haven't just been absolutely
annihilated in an election respond to
that by saying I'm not going to change
my thinking I was right the voters were
we've been virtually wiped out but I'm
just going to get drunk and have a laugh
about it you know you're not serious
you're not a serious political player
and you're actually letting down the
people you claim to be speaking isn't
the problem here Paul that we had a busy
day as you know we interviewed Eric
Hoffman earlier today and look at us as
well I mean one of the things that Eric
was talking about is essentially it's
very difficult for someone like yourself
or the views that you represent to to be
to get to a high prominent position now
in the Labor Party because the work
fringe and also that momentum fringe
essentially would immediately destroy
anyone who moves to the right on culture
and talks about immigration and and
family and all that kind of stuff as
racist nativist etc so if the solution
which the consensus seemed to be the
solution to Labour's problems is a
center-left person who's maybe
culturally on the socially conservative
side of things economically it could be
quite far left actually depending on how
you look at it that person cannot
succeed in the labour party as it's
constituted because they would never get
anywhere with those views
I think fair assessment I mean and
that's that's why I've said I think the
the Labour Party could be out of power
for at least 10 years and may not
actually ever be a party of government
again because I'm not convinced that
within the party you know lie enough
people who understand this and and
willing to do something about it now in
truth there's no real alternative at the
moment I mean I'm certainly would never
recommend that working-class people vote
sorry and I certainly would never
recommend that we all go off and join
the Tory party because that's not my
view the answer to the problems of
working-class people and the economic
inequalities and social injustice is in
society but no we need so we need to
find ways within the party ie to develop
the argument and to win the argument and
to bring people into the party or back
into the party you have abandoned the
party to support that argument I mean my
view is that the for the moment the
movement is still supporting the Labour
Party so the trade union movement which
is ostensibly at least the voice of
workers in this country
still supports the Labour Party and for
as long as the movement is there and for
as long as the you know workers see the
Labour Party as at least the trade
unions see the labor partners their
party rather than any other party that's
where the argument is going to be
political parties that have been set up
with the with the idea of stall means of
power of not traditionally had much
success in this country I'm you know
he's been tried with the SDP and other
organizations over the years but we're
still pretty much a two-party a
two-party state in that in that way so
out of the two I much prefer a Labour
government than the Natori government I
think part of the problem as well around
what you talked about is is the lack of
MPs who come from that working-class
background now I mean if he went back 20
or 30 years ago you would see on the
labor side of the house a significant
number of people who can genuinely
claims herds and working-class
backgrounds would have done ordinary
jobs you know some of the older
working-class MPs would have you know
works in the shipyards or down the mines
or in the steel works and things like
that now obviously we've gone through
the industrialization so a lot of those
jobs don't exist anymore but even so the
proportion of MPs who come through on
what I've called that conveyor belt if
you like where they're you go to
University and then they get a job in a
think-tank or a charity and then as a
research assistants or an MP and then
their parachute it entered into a safe
seat themselves and consequently we have
no real understanding of the lives of
ordinary ordinary working-class people
that has become a problem because it's a
set of working-class people look at
those those people say we just don't
share the same background we don't share
the same priorities I mean there are
still people in the party you do get it
you know with I'm involved with the blue
labour group within the within the party
it's small but it punches above its
weight and it's been completely
vindicated by recent events you know
we've been within blue labour we've been
arguing for some time now that this was
that this was going to happen and you
know blue labour has been talking
the language of family and the language
of Patriots is in the language of
community isn't afraid to discuss issues
around immigration so you know hopefully
some of that stuff can break through but
even even with that you see the response
to you know since the election blue
label's taken off to a certain degree I
mean thousands more followers on social
media and people starting to take an
interest in its ideas but even around
that you see some people in the party
saying you know we don't hand a part yet
over to these racists and and you
realize you know what you know what
distance there is - there is - travel
but but what else can you do but have a
go but so you're saying blue labor now
that is a term that I've heard used and
explained what blue labor is what your
modus operandi is essentially and how
you differ from the modern-day labor
party someone heard someone say once it
was very good description that blue
labor is socialism with a small C I
think it's a pretty good way of
describing it so so it's some people
call it Blair ISM and absolutely not
blue labor were amongst Blair's
strongest critics because of his
infatuation with with the market so so
it's certainly not Blair right in that
respects but it's not in that respect
but it's not particularly korbinite
either although it's you know expressed
a lot of sympathy quite rightly in my
view with some of the sort of economics
around Corbin ISM and then the need to
tackle austerity and stuff but it's a
group of people who actually understand
that that we are social and parochial
beings with an attachment community and
to country it's a family and that if you
violate that whether it's through you
know having an unfettered market where a
vast movements of capital which can
leave destruction in its wake where you
know money can just fly abroad and you
see the industrialization etc on the one
hand or you know vast movements of
people on the other
which are brought about through you know
an unregulated market and through the
philosophy of open borders and liberal
cosmopolitanism that can also violate
people's sense of community and sense of
stability and that if you're going to do
these things if you're gonna if you're
gonna bring on change in communities and
change will always happen in communities
no communities never going to stay the
same and if that's what anyone's arguing
for then they're in for a nasty surprise
change will happen people will move on
capitalism is a system where where
you're not you're not going to stop that
change to a certain degree but what you
can do is have measures to ameliorate it
and what you can do is make sure it's
done in such a in such a way where you
know people's sense of place and
belonging is not violated and that's
something that you know people within
the Labor Party and beyond just if not
have not understood so blue labor is
trying to articulate some of those
arguments that you know we don't want an
unregulated or dominant market on the
one hand we don't particularly want an
overbearing state on the other hand we
want politics to be much more about
community much more democratic rooted in
our local democratic institutions and
also you've got so you've got to respect
people's people's place and belonging
and community I'm going to ask you're
quite a grim question Apple like I
listened to that and as a voter if you
put that forward to me I would vote for
it in a heartbeat that's essentially
what I believe in
however do not think and you look at the
Labour Party the way it is now the range
of candidates and just think you're
fighting a losing battle here I think
it's a tough challenge describe is
pretty tough but but no I mean I'm not
I'm not claiming that that the Labour
Party is going to sort of change in the
way that I want to see it changed
anytime soon and that we're gonna we're
gonna win power on that basis I think we
are we're in for a real long slog in the
labour party and I'm not completely
optimistic that we're going to win that
battle and you know because I think
because as I said the party's so
dominated by people who are so
entrenched in their own ideology you
know as on the one hand the sort of
liberal cosmopolitan glow
list open borders middle class won't
liberal view on the other the sort of
far left revolutionary view that is very
difficult to and even this even what's
happened with this election he's not
shift in many of those people even
showing them the stats of the election
and saying look these are the places we
lost the working class voted this way
for a touring government and they are
not coming to us and these are the
reasons and some of them refused to
accept it and it's difficult for people
to be honest you know you can't you
can't expect people to to change their
minds overnight when they've been wedded
to a particular principle or ideology or
philosophy for so long and it's
difficult for people to sort of shift
their position and so you do have to be
a little bit sensitive with people
around that but at the moment I've seen
no real signs among lots of people that
was even any willingness to accept what
the electorate has just told them so
they say you know we're in for about
well sounds like the Labor Party doesn't
represent your views anymore very much
why are you still in the Labor Party
well I mean first of all what I mean in
in the Labor Party for 25 years I'm not
you know particularly keen sir to just
give up the fight and so I hand it over
to people in some cases who have only
been in the labor party five minutes I
don't mean that in a disparaging come
into the party in turn and to argue
their case but yeah I don't believe that
because the the party is shifted its
stance even though that shift has been
pretty significant you just you just
give up the fight and actually if you
look at the history of the Labor Party
it has swung from left to right and you
know all manner of things in between in
their sort of hundred years or so
hundred and fourteen years that the
party as a party has been has been in
existence and took me honest before 2015
who would have predicted Kuhlman ISM you
know who would have thought for a moment
that call bin
in you know fairly sort of obscure
backbencher 20 or 30 odd years was going
to come out of nowhere and storms a
victory and and completely change the
the party not completely changed the
party because I think it been certainly
in terms of the liberal globalism at
going it been going in that way for some
time but nonetheless had quite a
significant impact on it so you know if
you'd have said so if you'd have said
someone in momentum pre 2015 you know do
you ever think you can win the part
you're away from Blair ISM Brown ISM Ed
Miliband they're probably gone well
course not but it happened so yeah you
know it's not impossible now we were
talking in a fir in a previous interview
to Lord Adonis who Thomas Lee a Labour
peer he was waxing lyrical getting very
nostalgic about Blair saying that that's
when the Labour Party was at its peak
that's when they were winning elections
that's when they were winning heart and
minds and maybe we need to go back to
that do you know I think that's a
disastrous route I think if you look at
and I think the thing that proves that
if you look at the change UK or whatever
they called themselves in the end they
just kept changing their name was the 11
defectors who came from the Tories and
Labour and South change UK and they said
and that was frankly a Blair right
project in terms of his philosophy it
was all about centuries and it was all
about being probably you've been open
borders being liberal etc and and they
if they died a death it was completely
stillborn as as some of us predicted
because I really don't think there is
any desire among people to certainly not
a mass of people to go back to that and
I think it's probably fair to say that
if you look at Blair ISM it contributed
in many ways to what we saw in 2016 we
bring sit and what we've seen since I
mean my assessment is when you I'm not
someone who completely rubbish is that
Labour government by the way I think I
think Blair did some good things I think
the Labour government did some good
things I think we have to recognize that
hey there was such a desire to get rid
of the Tories in 97 that you know donkey
could have stood as a Labour Party
leader and and become Prime Minister
frankly and I think for a number of
years after that Petraeus was such a
shambles that it was pretty easy for
labour to carry on winning victories but
even if you look at that period that's
sort of 10 years of Blair ISM and 3
years of Gordon Brown you saw the stats
prove that actually there there was a
drip drip away of votes from labour
I mean ferry nothing started from a
high-water mark in 1997 when it had a
huge landslide but nonetheless it shared
millions of voters including
working-class voters up until 2010 when
Cameron came to power with the with the
coalition and that was I think because
some of this stuff around their
philosophy have been probably you being
sort of uber liberal becoming a party of
the cities and the middle class
metropolitan elite the Hampstead rather
than Hartlepool had started to kick in
during that period and I think what
happened in 2016
didn't come out of a clear blue sky it
had been brewing for years and some of
that stuff can be traced back to Blair
so the idea that you know you just set
up a new changing okay or you you try
and push the Labour Party back in that
direction I think he's a non-starter and
the SDP would you join them because I'm
looking on the surface pool and you seem
completely aligned with their viewpoints
no no essentially I know some some
people involved with this new SDP and
they're they're good people and I
respect them but no I've got no
intention of joining as I said as I said
before I mean there's not a great record
of new parties coming out and nowhere
and trying to challenge the two main
parties you know much of its philosophy
is good around you know much more focus
on the community communitarian stuff but
and part of the difficulty is frankly is
that if you speak to people in the in
the labour party like me the name SDP is
pretty toxic we go back to the 1980s
when the old SDP with the Gang of Four
split away from the Labour Party in the
early eighties
contributed to ten years of fattier ISM
by splitting the the left vote then
there's a lot of that baggage as well so
so no I wish them well but you know like
the name there's been a great chatting
to you again the last question we
normally ask is what's the one thing no
one is talking about that we should be
talking about but actually the question
I want to ask you is I mean I have to
say the most common comment on our
previous interview with you other than
all our female viewers saying how much
they liked you was the fact that a lot
of people were saying well if this guy
represented the Labour Party I'd vote
for him and frankly I don't agree with
you on economics on probably most of
things but I'd vote for you so are you
planning to stand at any point for
Parliament that's constant and flirting
with you by the way yes frankly
genuinely I don't have me in Thailand
people like me you know there are a few
people like me around and there's lots
of very good people you know within blue
labour for example we're articulate in
these arguments I don't think that large
parts of the party want people like me
whether it's me or someone else putting
these ideas in the higher levels of the
the party or in Parliament because I
think they are just so uncomfortable
with them and it just you know it just
runs completely up against their own
philosophy that they would that they
would hate the idea of Paul Emery being
in Parliament speaking on behalf of the
Labour Party so I don't think that's
going to happen anytime soon see to me
that that's a huge problem to me Paul
the fact that that is the case is a huge
problem for the Labour Party I mean as
you say I
until someone like you can stand for the
Labour Party and be elected as an MP or
even Prime Minister frankly I don't see
how they ever gonna win back the country
I just don't see that as possible
because what you represent
is the views of millions of people up
and down the country and if they can't
have someone like you even present as
part of a broader conversation then are
going to win the country back it's just
not going to happen I mean always
interesting is when you were talking
about blow labor isn't that what just
cool been represented if he was just
being honest really calming blue labor
right yeah Kobe was certainly a brick
city yeah and he is doing his heart the
brexit airburst someone said i think it
was a good way of put it he was placed
under ideological house arrest by the
Labor Party but he's a brick city I know
I don't think he would be blue labor
I think certainly on the on some of the
economic stuff you would have blue labor
and Corbin would have a lot of sympathy
with each other
I don't think calming gets the sort of
cultural side of it and so I think
partly because he's embedded in his
Islington constituency and he's got very
much that North London worldview where
he you know what's been called citizens
of nowhere that view of the world should
be open borders and that there should be
this constant churn in society and we
should all be sort of very liberal
that's all john lennon approach to
society and i don't think he I think
he's a nice guy by the way I've got to
say that I mean I rather the
firefighters in some fire station for
many years he was a local MP he had come
and stand on our picket lines when we
were on strike I think some of the
treatment meted out to him has been been
pretty disgraceful so on a personal
level I think he's a nice guy but no I
don't think I don't think he understands
the blue labour argument very much I
just think he got beaten up by a shark
or every day I think he started out as a
you know we're you know
preme probe writer and ash slowly hmm
well that's one of the problems the ash
Sarkis and the iving Joneses and the
pool Masons I think who
ideology got us into this mess and now
trying to tell us how to get out of it
I respect them but they're not the
answer they've got is so spectacularly
wrong that actually people need to think
hard before investing any faith in their
strategy for putting things right well I
do hope that we at some point live in
the world where people a you can
represent the Labour Party because I
think that would be a much better world
than the one we live in today but it's
going to be a tough challenge
[Laughter]
well Paul thank you so much for coming
back on the show it's been a pleasure is
there anything else you want to say
before we go because we have a nasty Oh
our final questions or any issues that's
been burning in the back your mind other
than the Labour Party on the issue that
there's always burning away that never
really gets much coverage I may have
mentioned this on the previous edition
if I'd if I did I apologize but I'll say
it again anyway is the issue of cuts to
the Fire and Rescue Service in this
country I'm a firefighter by trade have
been a firefighter for 23 years or
whatever it is now and we have seen huge
attacks to the Fire and Rescue Service
very few media organizations reports it
we've seen reduction in the number of
firefighters over the last 10 years have
something like 12,000 a quarter of all
firefighters firefighter posts have gone
we've seen scores of fire stations up
and down the country shut all in the
name of austerity we see in response
times getting longer we seen a rise in
the number of deaths by fire in some
places and firefighters who constantly
put their lives on the line of because
we saw the tragic incidents like
grenfell Tower and not being given the
tools to do the job you know they're not
particularly paid well but they just
simply asked that they get the tools to
do the job that they're brave enough to
do and more and more those resources are
being taken away from them and it's a
huge issue and it deserves to get more
attention than it does I apologize from
my insensitive a question of saying is
any issue burning at the back of you you
brought up well and we did talk about it
last time it is a very important issue
so thank you for raising it thank you
for coming back as always we'll put Paul
social media details in the video and
make sure you read his columns are
unheard he's always really really
interesting thank you for watching and
we'll see you in a week's time with
another brilliant episode take care CNN
come sweet guys thanks for watching guys
as always subscribe to the YouTube
channel click the bell button next to
subscribe button so you get notified
when a video comes out and follow us on
all the social media at trigger pot and
also leave us a nice review on iTunes
and spread the word